one of the scariest things about the
Wuhan coronavirus one of the many
reasons all of us have long been so
afraid of it has always been how little
we know about it Ebola malaria cholera
obviously those are dangerous diseases
they've killed millions but on the whole
we understand them pretty well the
fundamentals anyway anyway we know how
easily they spread we know how deadly
they are this disease by contrast is
entirely new it's literally a novel
coronavirus early accounts of the
mystery illness coming from central
China could be transmitted far more
easily than the flu and that the death
rate was remarkably high some reports
suggested it could kill two three five
even eight percent of all those who got
it
worst-case scenarios predicted millions
and millions of people would die the
public was horrified they still are but
how afraid should they be many people
are still dying in this pandemic
including here in the United States
beyond that fact we still don't have the
numbers we need to fully understand
what's happening around as too few
people have been tested and yet as of
tonight there are some suggestions of
good news we want to bring them to you
here's one between March 22nd and April
4th a total of 215 pregnant women
delivered babies at New York
Presbyterian Allen Hospital and Columbia
University
Irving Medical Center every single one
of these women was screened for the
corona virus it turned out that 33 of
them had it that's more than 15% of the
total group of the infected 29 of them
that's about 88% of them were totally
asymptomatic so think about what that
might mean if we extrapolated it
citywide as of April 4th New York had
more than 60,000 confirmed cases of the
corona virus in a little over 2,200
deaths if more than 15% of New York's
population was infected that would
suggest a total of 1.3 million cases in
New York with only about a hundred and
fifty thousand them showing symptoms in
other words the virus would be far more
widespread that we expected it to be but
also far less deadly than we expected
the actual death rate would not be three
or four percent it would be closer to
0.2 percent that would be great now we
don't know for certain that's the case
215 people is a
small sample and in this specific case
it's not a representative sample
hospitals are major vectors for the
transmission of cronin virus pregnant
women tend to spend a lot of time in
hospitals pregnant women are also
younger and healthier than most people
so it's possible they're also less
likely to exhibit symptoms of the virus
we don't know on the other hand this is
not the only study that suggests these
trends in Scotland researchers tested
500 people three weeks into the outbreak
there more than one percent tested
positive for anybody's to Crona virus
that is 12 times greater than the
confirmed caseload in that country at
that time twelve times more in Denmark a
little over a month into the outbreak
only 0.1% of the population was infected
according to official numbers and yet a
screening of 1500 people found that 2.7
percent actually had antibodies that
would mean the true death rate from
chrono virus there might be 127th as
high as they thought it was meanwhile in
Germany the official death rate from the
corona virus stands today at about two
and a half percent that's a horrifying
number and it may be real on the other
hand in the town of gang geld where
large-scale random testing has been
performed the death rate was found to be
just 0.37 percent that's a fraction of
the official number it's barely 1/7 of
it so all of this is very encouraging
news if the infection is more widespread
than we thought by definition that means
the virus is less deadly that would mean
our burden on the healthcare system
would be lower than we expected it to be
in fact we are seeing that it would also
mean that chrono virus may be closer
than we knew to running its course it
would mean an awful lot of people have
already been infected with it and then
recovered without even knowing it and
those people could pause and let relief
sweep over them and then get back to
their lives above all if this is true if
these trends hold it would mean that the
rest of us could be slightly less
terrified going forward yes this is
awful yes people are dying yes they will
continue to die here in the US but it
would not quite be the plague we thought
it was and that might give us some
perspective we could begin maybe to
think clearly again most of us won all
of that badly but do or
leaders want that sometimes when you
watch them you begin to suspect they're
secretly enjoying our fear dr. J Bennett
Chara is at Stanford University medical
professor he's been investigating the
death rate from coronavirus a
fascinating an important number and he
joins us tonight
dr. thanks so much for coming on what
are you concluding about the real death
rate the actual death rate from this
virus I think what I think based on the
evidence I've seen so far it's it's
likely orders of magnitude lower than
the initial estimates the the World
Health Organization put an estimate out
that I think is initially 3.4 percent
it's very unlikely it's anywhere near
that it's it's much likely much closer
to the death rate that you see from the
flu per case but the problem of course
is that we don't have a vaccine so in
that sense it's more it's more deadly
and more widespread than the flu right
and it overwhelms hospital systems in
ways the flu doesn't but her case I
don't think it's as deadly as people
have thought I know it's very hard to
come up with any kind of firm numbers in
the absence of of widespread testing but
do you think it's likely that there are
large numbers of Americans who've been
infected recovered and didn't know it
yes I believe that that is true in fact
we're gonna start to know that very very
soon I've been working on studies with
some colleagues of mine in in santa
clara county in Los Angeles County and
and and also a large nationwide study
working with major league baseball
employees not just athletes but all the
employees very soon we're gonna have a I
think much more accurate understanding
of how widespread this is and then we'll
as you said it very well in your
introduction we'll also know much better
how deadly it actually is evidence
really around the world is is flowing in
and it's it's really seems like there's
many many cases of the corona virus that
that we haven't identified with with the
the testing regimens that we've had
around the world many orders of
magnitude more people have been infected
with it I think I think that we realize
and that as you as you rightly pointed
out means that we that the death rate is
actually lower than we then people
realize also by orders of magnitude
so one of the one of the destructive
byproducts of this pandemic is fear
which is itself I would say it clearly
is hurting people
you're an American in addition to a
physician and a researcher based on the
research that you have done are you more
afraid or less afraid than you were when
you begin I'm less afraid than I was
when I began I'm I think I mean I I've
heard so many stories of people who
can't hug their grandkids which we're
scared to hug there because they don't
they don't want to get the virus from
their from their from their kids as
they're older I've heard lots of stories
of even if like husbands and wives they
can't both won't hug each other because
of the wife is a nurse in the frontline
worker I think this sort of the
understanding really the true death rate
for the death rate somewhere near one in
a thousand would you would you not hug
your wife
I mean if it's three and a hundred you
act very differently than if it's one in
a thousand so I'm hoping we're actually
get back numbers in in place we'll be
able to really sort of tell the fear
that's out there well that is one of the
most reassuring things I've heard in a
long time doctor thank you truly for
coming on tonight I appreciate it my
pleasure